trois invités dont l'un qu'il ya des
fuites pour en parler c'est jean
quatremer bonsoir jean quatremer
correspondant européen du quotidien
libération c'est ce que j'ai juste
renversé mon voeu à bruxelles c'est
l'âge on revient le dossier du jour que
la transpiration saviez vous que de tout
temps les humains rivalisent
d'imagination pour se faire suer se
serait même pour certains un mal pour un
bien mais il ne te remonte le temps à la
découverte
[Rires]
ces adeptes de la transpiration
des variations de température
impressionnante à quelques dizaines de
mètres place de la bastille samedi le
sol monte à 57 degrés les feuilles de
cet arbre était à 32 et près du canal
saint martin ce mur à l'ombre affiché 22
degrés c'est ce qu'a révélé un urbaniste
thermomètre laser en main l'outil mesure
la température des surfaces et montre
l'importance du mobilier urbain lors des
épisodes caniculaires record détenu
place de la république par un banc à
plus de 50 9 degrés mon époux transpire
beaucoup de la fesse gauche à chaque
élection depuis quelques années aux
anneaux on en rigole enfin pardon mais
quelle est votre explication la fesse
gauche à chaque état il est pas il pas
gauche et enfin le risque
neurologique ce niveau du secteur ce
qu'on appelle secteur de la queue de
cheval il n'y a pas de mauvais jeu de
mots
je lui ai offert un beau gars sont avec
ma tête dessus
ça te plaît
au cours d'une de vos planches on
découvre ne pas entrer envoient leurs
ici la chaussette et sur la porte seul
espace de vie privée de la navigation
alors il ya un dessin de chaussettes et
arizona qu'est ce qui se passe sur les
bateaux en général y assure une pièce
pour la vie privée des membres
d'équipage
je pense que vous en doutez bien pas du
tout
voilà que signifie faire crac-crac faire
l'amour
[Musique]
je crois aux galipettes
faire des galipettes et fait voyez ce
que notre carrière
donc il ya des rapprochements entre
hommes et femmes il ya toujours un
endroit où les choses sont possibles
enfin équivalent à tout faire de
rapprochement voilà donc la règle de la
chaussette c'est de ne pas rentrer quand
il une seule la porte voilà
on va pas vous demander si vous avez
utilisé la chaussette méprendre veux pas
le savoir il faut qu'il apporte j'avance
je crois là comme ça au moins
je suis tranquille les magies tôt lundi
matin après la plus grande partie du
succès de notre groupe c'est qu'on était
les meilleurs
[Musique]
quand je suis à l'étranger on me prend
pour david guetta quand je suis à lille
marc et d'aller à las vegas et mixe dans
l'hôtel donc les filles viennent me voir
ils me disent à rioz david guetta je dis
non à n'ont hélas mes copains retend de
voir les filles et ils font c'est david
guetta mais il veut être peinard c'est
souvent tarifs et les filiales de gaza a
besoin d'avoir confiance en quelqu'un de
voir au jour le jour comment ça se passe
extra mais moi j'ai besoin d'avoir un
retour en fait
je peux pas sauvé quelqu'un qui veut pas
l'être non choix fin c'est la phrase
je les pique père m'a pris parce que et
moi enfin regarde sa vie
moi je parlais de sauver si on vous dit
demande en mariage à venise vous pensez
gondole pont du rialto et place saint
marc mais le summum du romantisme très
peu pour salvatore réveillant ce
touriste sicile et en vacances en couple
à venise donc a fait sa demande au
supermarché et armand
et c'est la mairie
et sa compagne tiziana a dit oui au
rayon surgelés
[Musique]
ok
geoffrey est ce que vous souhaitez
divorcées ou est-ce que vous souhaitez
rester mariés
[Musique]
moi je souhaite divorcer
d'accord
s'il dit je vous pose la question est
également oui je sais le divorce est
aussi